oha patricia wechselt gerade ihre
sitzposition das heißt nichts gutes ich
glaube ich auch aber ich habe mein
lieblings café genetisch und eine steile
these wir brauchen überhaupt keine
models ich weiß nicht warum wir einen
beruf brauchen der frauen wie lebendige
kleiderständer irgendwo lang marschieren
ist warum wir es unseren kindern antun
idealmaße vorzugeben nachdem die
irgendwann groß werden müssen ist wir
sagen das aber ist ein kinder ganz ich
erziehe meine beiden töchter sein dass
wir ihnen das überhaupt mit gehen müssen
und ich finde diese show ist unfassbar 6
ist schwer beurteilen frauen daran wie
sie aussehen und dann gibt die den kern
seiner häuser habe ich schon auf rot ja
an der georgia brauchen wir überhaupt
und warum sich aber werden lassen oder
selber entscheiden was sie wollen wenn
es im mitteldrittel das jedoch muss
nadal der problemlos ist doch nicht teil
des problems ist wie etwas kreieren was
junge menschen unter druck setzt
natürlich können diese menschen
freiwillig hin
ja die gehen freiwillig hin und weil sie
weil sie von diesem system eben gezeigt
bekommen
du musst so aussehen es ist teil der
lego in deiner mullahs mama deiner
tochter dann zu sagen musst du nicht
willst aber leute die die sind normal
wunderschön geboren warum sollen sie
nicht damit sensors wird man sagen sie
über ein fußballer abschaffen weil ich
es eben schon auch wichtig finde gerade
bei kindern wo er noch viel in
entwicklung ist wenn der etwas
bestimmtes vorgelebt wird auch an
vorbildern das heute ja nicht bei
germany's next topmodel auf sondern das
geht ja bei den influenza weiter und den
hiphop girls beispielsweise das war mit
natürlich auf den frauen mit einhergeht
stichwort auch operation perfektion
sozusagen optimierung der ob gaddafi und
alles natürlich nicht einmal das also
germany's next topmodel ist natürlich
eine sendung die das mit bedient und ich
sag mal ich oute mich jetzt hier ich
gucke die sendung aber mir geht es nicht
gut dabei aber ich gucke sie war nicht
vorgesehen
ich gucke nur weil meistens er sich
dabei sogar eine tüte chips und dann und
danken danach geht es mir schlecht aber
ich denke du bist nichts und du nur du
bist auch nicht so hübsch und wenn ich
das als erwachsene frau schon habe sage
ich jetzt mal dass so ein bisschen
despektierlich wie soll seinen kindern
gehen also ich glaube schließen
die quote nach oben wenn die quote oben
bleibt für steht jetzt das sagen und was
sie eventuell rückt und freundlich zu
sein den ganzen winter sein ich habe
diesem einem anderen leben sind 40 jahre
jansons nähkästchen plaudert ein wenig
geschadet
ich habe mein studium mal wieder
reduziert ich habe mein studium damit
finanziert sie will ihn vielleicht genau
unwahrscheinlich vor allem die
internationalen wahl muss ich dir sagen
ich weiß so ein bisschen so eine
landpomeranze muss man wirklich sagen
meine mami hat er mir später gesagt was
kann ich was aus dir geworden ist ja du
warst immer richtig so ich dir so die
landpomeranze und es mir hat es damals
schon geholfen
also selbstständig so werden
kommunikative zu werden sich auch mehr
zu behaupten vor einem internationalen
damals also gut aber alles hat natürlich
seine zeit und deiner zeit war wie eine
revolution also als du das noch gemacht
hast da war das ja mit ganz viel
durchsetzungskraft verbunden
germany's next topmodel sende ich mach
das gegenteil da geht es ja stimmt darum
ein bootcamp sozusagen mentalität und
richtig ist der der sich unterordnet
richtig ist der den im umfeld der
richter sie person heiden die sich
anpasst und unterordnet ja das ist auch
die den job kriegt aber nicht die die
widerspenstig ist nicht wie die auch
möglich ist und das ist nun nicht nur
das ist ein frauenbild ja aber hier
könnte man also die anderen eben nur
eine hypothese könnte man das was du
gerade gesagt dass auch in der
teamplayer buchen
aber die teamplayer mentalität wird ja
nicht beförderten dieser sendung am
anfang stehen die mädels sich immer
besser und im laufe der sendung
verstehen sie sich immer schlechter weil
nur eine germany's next topmodel werden
kann
ich habe das ist ja eigentlich sind es
ist dass uns hat ihre sendung wurde der
dinge lehren wir wissen das ja aber es
geht ja darum was macht das bei jungen
genau das ist mein punkt wir wissen dass
er gehen wir genau dieses wissen weiter
an unsere töchter nicht ein wie auch
immer finde ich das ist glaube ich
wichtig dass man da dann einfach
aufklären muss uns sagen kann auch was
eine miss germany kann einer sehr
gestandenen traumfrau werden wenn man
dieses haben doch das kann sich schon
ruhig so annehmen das ist so und
deswegen ist es glaube ich für mich ich
kann jetzt nur für mich sprechen ich
finde immer die aufklärung gehört dazu
und für mich gibt es auch ganz viele
andere sachen die sehr viel schlimmer
sind und frauenfeindlicher sind als
germany's next topmodel sara nuru ist ja
auch ein tolles beispiel dafür was aus
einem germany's next topmodel werden
kann nämlich heute eine sozial
unternehmerinnen unterwegs ist die seite
etwas passiert ja jetzt schon ja das
bringt leben wieder auch wie immer nicht
schwarz oder weiß
doch für mich schon aber weiß patricia
bis solchen weg wie sollte es zukünftig
ablaufende gehst oder das schenkst du
die ganzen kleider hängst du dann an
gleicher stelle um über den laufsteg
oder es sieht ja auch rudi mittig auf
der session mit bin dann sitze ich da
und sagen wir es so schlimm da sieht man
toll aus 90 60 90 steht das super und
was wäre wer kauft das es sind nicht die
frauen die alle diese kleidergröße haben
aber wenn tatsächlich in einer
modenschau sitze denke ich mir wir aber
so wie das bei mir nicht aussehen das
würde auch nicht so gibt es eigentlich
auch in meiner größe also natürlich ist
es völlig völlig an den bekannten hängst
du glauben nicht dass klientel was jetzt
die fische gut ansprechen soll meine
einkäufe die dort sie wissen ja die
angriffe dort von den firmen verstieße
die ihr dann aber letztendlich
eigentlich das klientel weil ich bin am
ende der endverbraucher und ich gestalte
die nachfrage für die einkäufer also
insofern auch wenn ich dort nicht sitze
bin ich natürlich die für die eingekauft
wird
und natürlich bin ich teil dieser
nachfrage und natürlich muss es
irgendwie von normalen frauen die
normale maße haben die kanne keinen
model sind die sich nicht runter hungern
und ein ideal entsprechen sondern von
tollen frauen und ich sage überhaupt
nicht dass models keine tollen frauen
oder das aus models nichts werden kann
ich glaube nur dass wir uns ein bild
schaffen das so engstirnig ist und auf
viele menschen so einen druck ausübt und
das brauchen wir nicht und da bloß
locker doch immer mehr auf das sind ja
jetzt auch immer mehr frauen die unter
der kategorie kirby fallen derzeit wird
ja schon einmal die werden als curry
verkauft und wir verkaufen recht aber
aber einfluss gehabt die sehr viel geld
machen auch damit mit ihren körper was
wir müssen natürlich jetzt die
diskussion könnte man erweitern wir uns
heute darüber da warst du nicht dabei
wir haben uns wahnsinnig darüber
aufgeregt dass 38 bis 38 körpergröße ist
das ist natürlich eine falsche
spiegelungen gesellschaft aber auch da
hieß es doch dass man dann sagt nein ist
es nicht wir wissen es doch für uns und
das dass ich frage mich aber auch
gleichzeitig warum gucken denn warum ist
die hauptzielgruppe von germany's next
topmodel frauen
weil natürlich wir nicht im innersten
jederzeit so wahnsinnig selbst sicher
sind dass wir sagen ach das ist ja toll
und das ist ja toll sondern weil wir
natürlich und auch wie mädchen außerhalb
nach außen schauen und uns daran
orientieren was ist ein schönheitsideal
und natürlich wollen ganz viel im
inneren dem auch entsprechen ich auch
ich möchte natürlich dass er sagt mensch
sieht toll aus hier dann pistazien anzug
und das wünschen wir uns alle aber wir
sollten es nicht auferlegen und wir
sollten versuchen uns beizubringen das
ist völlig okay ist außerhalb dieser box
zu sein
germany's next yabulu das galaxy reihe
das suggeriert es ist nur okay dabei ist
sie seien jetzt mal die menschen nicht
so dumm machen wir menschen haben auch
in gewissen menschenverstand glaube ich
und die meisten können auch selbst
beurteilen ob etwas gut ist oder
schlecht ist das sollten wir den
menschen glaube ich auch noch selbst
überlassen
clevere hoch intelligente mädels dabei
die frage ist nur was befördert wird
bittet nochmals die frage ist nur was
befördert wurde in den fingern oder muss
jede mark werbung verbieten heute
versteht es hier die werbung führen
damit man am ende nicht angucken meiner
meinung noch anfangen weil das handy die
ich am häufigsten sehr nah wo man
weiterfahren konnte nichtsdestotrotz die
gretchenfrage an dich jetzt vertreter
dürfen eine tätigkeit in der mitmachen
in ein paar jahren wenn sie dann wäre
mein absoluter albtraum gefolgt von mama
ich werde in florenz darin allerdings
sagen oder möbel und weiter was bleibt
da eigentlich noch genau rufe meine
tochter nicht mehr viel
es geht um unterschiedliche werte die
wir vermitteln müssen und da dazu kann
auch gehören dass man sich schön fühlt
und dass schönheit nicht bedeutet dumm
zu sein das wäre einseitig und wir
hatten tolle sagt und das entspricht
auch nicht der wahrheit ist einfach dann
auch mit kritischen augen sich das
anzugucken wenn man schon ausprobiert
zum beispiel ich kann mich ich habe mich
noch erinnern als ich in die politik
gegangen bin und so es war schon ein
gewisses vorurteil war immer da gewesen
also du musst jetzt erst mal dieses
vorurteil bekämpfen hübsch aber trotzdem
was ja das ist ganz klar du musst es
immer keinen mehr
das ist jetzt ein bisschen mehr geld als
sonst wenn so jemand neues kennen lernst
du bei null an und dann entweder positiv
und negativ aber du fängst du schon mal
- anja die kann ich gar nicht
intelligent sein wenn ich total spannend
bei der ich mal das ja dann auch
rechtsanwältin geworden und vielleicht
war das ja auch immer so eine motivation
zu sagen jetzt euch zeigen die 40 auf
jeden fall gerät zu kämpfen
wie sieht es bei dir aus mit deinen mit
deinen nächsten würdest du die dazu ich
möchte natürlich auch während die damit
beschäftigt sind die über menschenrechte
aufzuklären dass die red stars abfeiern
dana das ist halt so der großen schlimm
ich finde es jetzt in dem sinne nicht
schlimm aber ich möchte den halt auch
zeigen dass es auch andere frauen
rollenbilder gibt und ich bin gehe ich
gerne mit denen die buchhandlungen und
dann kaufen wir immer zusammen bücher
das mache ich meine nicht nennen kann
sich alle bücher aussuchen die ihr
wichtig sind und da sind dann auch
starke frauen dabei da ist dann auch das
schicksal von anne frank dabei genau wie
marie curie also mir geht einfach darum
mehr zu zeigen und dann kann sie sich
aussuchen und so lange die leseratte
bleibt kann sie auch die videos knacken
ist auch so wie ich das im buchhandel
ich liebe buchhandlung aber ich glaube
immer mehr bücher als was ich lese kann
ich gehe ständig also mehr gering
bleiben ist bei der balance ja also das
es dir ist die balance wichtig aber du
sagst aber wie soll das für dich aus dem
patricia wenn man jetzt munter macht
ohne models ja also auf kleiderstangen
oder laufen da dann wäre vielleicht
könnten wir mal in den ersten schritt
machen und anfangen wurden schauen mit
normalen frauen zusammen ein medial ja
es kann er auch sich mal mischen einfach
so wie wir als menschen sind dabei die
90 60 90 hat eine ist dabei die
kleidergröße 42 hat patricia es gibt
leider in berlin
aber es gibt es gibt nun auch für
übergrößen gibt es ganz normal dass die
wirklich abschaffen
ich möchte keine modenschau für
übergrößen ich möchte modenschauen für
frauen für uns alle wir sind alle einmal
den händler singh es gibt händler die
verkaufen zum beispiel nur übergrößen
die firma die haben sich darauf
spezialisiert
das sind ganz unterschiedliche moodle
branchen auch ja das gibt dann gibt es
welche da hast du welche boutiquen die
haben da nur bis größe meinen wegen 40
36 38 haben gar nicht mehr dann gibt's
die großen warenhäuser die haben
natürlich mehr das ist immer anders
[Musik]